How many ounces are
in 6 pounds?
So we have 6 pounds
and we need to
convert them to ounces.
And if you don't know it
already, you'll know it now,
that there are 16 ounces
per pound.
So what we want to do is we
want to have pounds in the
denominator.
It's in the numerator
right now.
So we want to divide by pounds
and multiply by ounces.
Maybe I'll write it out.
And I just told you
that there are 16
ounces for every 1 pound.
So if we multiplied these two
expressions, this pounds will
cancel with that pounds, and
we'll just be left with the
unit of ounces, which is what we
want, and we just multiply
6 times 16.
So it works out unit-wise, and
it makes sense as well.
If we have 16 ounces per pound,
and we have 6 pounds,
we just have to multiply
6 times 16.
That'll be the total number of
ounces we have. So this is
going to be equal to--
what's 6 times 16?
So if you take 16 times
6, 6 times 6 is 36.
Carry the 3.
6 times 1 is 6, plus 3 is 9.
So 6 times 16 is 96.
You have this divided by 1 here,
but that's not going to
change anything.
And then all we're
left with in the
dimensions are the ounces.
So 6 pounds are 96 ounces.